[Applaudissements]
on joue tous ensemble on va faire le
tour de l'actu avant dans un instant
dans TPMP la BRI la brigade de
répression de l'info avec Karim Zeribi
qui nous rejoint et Eric Naulleau arrivé
dans un instant ils seront face à Cyril
et Catalina porte parole de dernière
rénovation ils ont repeint l'Élysée là
de peinture orange là tout à l'heure là
les militants écologistes je leur ai
demandé s'ils veulent bien faire la
peinture à la maison
j'aurais un coup de gueule aujourd'hui
ah ah j'ai un coup de gueule il y a un
truc qui m'a pas plu et ça fait
énormément réagir c'est ça a généré je
crois plus de 200000 tweets
maltraitance dans les crèches nos
enfants sont-ils en danger on aura Julie
Fallon qui sera avec nous il Fallon
d'ailleurs parce qu'on n'est pas aux
États-Unis ancienne responsable d'une
crèche privée qui va nous raconter des
trucs incroyables vous allez voir on va
revenir bien sûr sur les infos du jour
et vous allez voir cette histoire on va
pouvoir faire beaucoup beaucoup de
choses grâce à une puce dans la peau
vous allez voir c'est un truc de fou
vraiment ça va arriver là vous allez
voir vous allez même toi tu vas le faire
là bientôt
si tu peux te calmer
et surtout ne manquez pas la fin de
l'émission est-ce que ça va secouer on
aura avec nous celui qui a été écarté de
France Télévisions il y a une pétition
donc tout le monde parle actuellement
pour son retour pour les JO c'est
patrick Montel rappelez tous patrick
Montel tout le monde le sait il sera là
et apparemment Patrick et très très
colère il va nous raconter son éviction
vous allez voir cette histoire est
complètement folle et c'est vrai que
beaucoup beaucoup de gens le réclament
il a choisi TPMP pour parler vous allez
voir c'est une histoire de dingue et
patrick Montel en ce moment on parle que
de lui tout le monde veut qu'il revienne
pour les JO vous allez voir je pense que
avec ce qui va dire ce soir demain ça va
secouer on va être en Orangina
mais bon c'est pas grave alors toi
je vais faire ça en gros c'est de l'actu
d'accord alors en gros je suis devenu
journaliste depuis peu et je vais vous
faire un peu deviner les actus bon avec
mon langage et tout donc je sais pas si
vous allez comprendre mais bon ça va le
faire c'est quoi la première alors la
première actu donc en gros il y a le
rappeur là qui avait géré Rihanna une
époque là j'irai rien oublié ah ouais
mais tu es sûr qu'il a géré ouais ouais
il a géré t'inquiète pas
je suis bien renseigné
il était en concert et il a pris un mec
dans le public il a régalé c'est un truc
de ouf le gars il était refait
franchement le gars il a la chance il a
passé le meilleur concert de sa vie le
gars il est reparti plein aux as ah pas
mal pas mal alors est-ce que vous avez
l'info je vous rappelle qu'il y aura
bien sûr des cadeaux en fin de mois pour
le meilleur élève pour l'instant le
meilleur élève c'est Moundir ah là
aujourd'hui donc essayez de prendre de
l'avance alors les chéris donc
toi tu dis c'est Drake
je sais pas ce qu'il a fait qu'est-ce
qui se passe alors est-ce que c'est
Drake qui est une nouvelle fois offert
quelque chose à un fan il avait déjà
offert un sac exactement je crois qu'il
est offert de l'argent d'accord combien
50000 dollars c'est une bonne réponse de
Gilbert
lors d'un concert à Las Vegas
le rappeur Drake a été pris d'affection
pour un fan à qui avait vendu ses
meubles pour pouvoir payer sa place il
lui a donc offert 50000 dollars regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis rassuré merci voilà merci alors
la dernière fois il avait donné un sac
un sac d'une très grande marque le sac
avait une valeur d'environ 30 000
dollars ouais ouais le sac je veux te
dire ouais regardez la vidéo a été
partagée sur les réseaux sociaux et
immédiatement devenu viral tu l'avais vu
ça
[Rires]
je crois que j'ai pas vu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il avait aussi déjà donné 50 000 dollars
en 2018 à une étudiante pour qu'elle
finisse ses études donc en fait il est
assez connu pour ça c'est fort les plus
riches à 400 millions de dollars et
c'est celui qui a fait le plus d'argent
avec un concert en un soir il a fait 5
millions en une soirée c'est 400 euros
la place en moyenne
donc déjà il y a le gars qui
a la crit en gros j'ai vendu mes meubles
pour venir à deux côtés
mais moi je trouve que c'est bizarre en
fait c'est-à-dire que quand on est on
n'a pas d'argent on vend ses meubles on
se met en danger pour aller à un concert
de Drake on a des responsabilise
complètement les gens mais il y a eu
d'ailleurs des commentaires sur sur
Instagram ou sur Twitter après cette
vidéo qui disait alors donc dès que dès
qu'on dit un peu tout et n'importe quoi
Drake vient donc on va ça va être un
concours à de à qui va mettre la
pancarte la plus moi
les meubles Didier mobico
[Rires]
qui m'a dit qu'il avait été assez choqué
également voilà de deux
questions il a toujours été proche de
ses fans effectivement il a donné à
Miami il a donné un sac pour lui ça
représente pas grand chose mais c'est un
beau geste je crois pas du tout que ce
soit fake et d'ailleurs aux États-Unis
avec la seule question que je me pose et
dis-moi grec j'aime bien un magasin mais
il a une réserve derrière
[Rires]
sac non non l'autre modèle frère tu peux
aller voir en réserve pendant que tu
chantes non mais c'est une canard et le
mec qui sort des sacs qui sort des
bagues
parce que les gens je sais pas si ça
vous le fait à vous sur les réseaux
sociaux ils demandent des invitations
quand c'est la dernière avant les
vacances des fois de Noël ou la dernière
de l'année ce qui savent que tu vas
faire des cadeaux alors tu es peut-être
un petit Drake aussi toi parce que tu
fais des cadeaux à tout public
ce soir
et oui bonsoir j'ai juste une question
il donne un sac Chanel à 3 50000 balles
alors c'est pas Chanel
ça se passe très bien dans la foule il y
a 10000 personnes dans la foule avec
donne le sac et sur le sac
c'est une bonne question il fait
protéger les gens à qui donne de
sécurité il s'occupe de ça
il leur mettait une capote
une autre personne c'est pas du tout
Drake vas-y non pas trop non vas-y frère
alors en gros il y a un mec un blond là
qui gueule souvent dans la salle là avec
plein de politiques plein de ministres
tout ça et ben apparemment ça serait
fait péta des affaires en sortant de ça
et il était très très vénère et
franchement il a pas kiffé et il était
déjà venu ici je crois ça fait un peu de
bois
ce mec j'aime ce mec ça serait pas un
député qu'est-ce qu'il a eu un truc il
s'est fait voler quelque chose dans la
caisse de son pote je crois il s'est
fait voler sans la voiture ta tablette
l'Assemblée nationale donne à ses 577
députés chacun a droit à une tablette
numérique d'accord parce que ça leur
permet d'avoir accès aux amendements et
cetera lui il dans la voiture de son
colocataire et il s'est fait braquer
enfin il s'est fait fracturer la voiture
le colocataire il y avait la tablette
dedans et donc évidemment il a été porté
plainte et voilà c'est pas très
responsable de sa part d'avoir laissé
une tablette aussi hein
qui ramène en soirée des documents
confidentialités
il a des informations confidentielles et
c'est marrant parce que les filles
passent leur temps à à minimiser la
sécurité en France et là il est victime
de ça lui-même ça montre que même à lui
ça peut lui arriver et je trouve que
c'est vraiment irresponsable de sa part
alors de de trimballer ça n'importe
quoi et on s'est rendu compte que sa
tablette était déjà sur un site de
petites annonces je vous jure que c'est
vrai euh regardez bonjour je vends la
tablette tactile d'un député je laisse
tout contenu à l'intérieur à savoir le
livre audio comment squatter un
appartement pour Lénine
l'application dis Cyril pour s'embrouer
ses amis et plein d'autres trucs qui
servent à rien mais qui font kiffer la
France insoumise à venir chercher à la
Factory à Boulogne demander
merci
le point lui Boyard c'est pour Delphine
pour Valérie c'est pour
ça merci en tout cas Valérie je donne un
point à Valérie Bénaïm un point Delphine
et je mets un point à chaque carte le
trio par contre les autres vous pouvez
vous gratter merci troisième actu mon
bébé alors il y a un pays je sais pas
trop où mon mamie c'est là d'où vous
venez moi ouais oui toi je crois que
c'est toi et un pays
où tu arrives bon à moitié on va dire
que maman dans la
logements ils veulent changer le nom du
pays
qui veut changer de nom de pays
c'est ça c'est vrai l'Inde il y a voilà
il faut changer de pays il faut changer
de nom là pour échanger non rapidement
des faits le Premier ministre indien
soit de supprimer le symbole persistant
de la colonisation britannique l'Inde
pourrait donc prochainement devenir le
baratte le baratin
en fait c'est pour ça que que
l'info un peu chuté parce qu'en fait
pour le G20 ils avaient envoyé une
invitation où ils avaient déjà changé le
nom India en baratte et donc on s'est
dit bon ben c'est fini finalement maudit
va vouloir vraiment changer
officiellement le nom de
il paraît ils vont déjà qu'ils sont
peuplés il paraît que ça va être bondé
bon débarrasse
c'est tout pour moi
c'est arrivé comme ça
parce que Inde c'est pas du tout leur
nom ça a été imposé par les Anglais les
barattes c'est l'ancien nom en sanskrit
donc moi je trouve ça formidable ils ont
tout à fait raison
du baratte non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as perdu des trucs
[Rires]
alors là c'est un délire alors c'est
quoi c'est une toute nouveauté en gros
il y a un son qui a super bien marqué
cet été et en gros en fait il y a une
meuf qui chante sauf qu'en vrai c'est
pas elle qui chante ouais c'est ça alors
là j'en ai perdu quelques-uns je pense
mais en fait non c'est un ordinateur qui
prend la voix de la vraie chanteuse et
qui modifie et en fait c'est un
ordinateur qui fait la venue le tube de
l'État
c'est même pas elle qui chante en fait
c'est une chanteuse très connue elle
s'est retrouvée sur un son en fait ils
ont fait un soin à partir de savoir un
son qui était déjà existant ils ont mis
sa voix et c'est devenu le tube de l'été
et sur Tik Tok c'est le son voilà que
tout le monde écoute c'est con parce que
c'est Angèle exactement ils ont repris
une chanson de Gazo exactement
[Musique]
moi j'aime bien l'original et très forte
et bah celle-là aussi tu vois elle a
entendu la chanson angèle a dit elle
avait peur pour son métier
[Musique]
elle boit du taquin
sa tête est géniale
surtout ce passage là qu'elle vient de
faire voilà parce que là les équipes ont
mis le passage souvent
et voilà mais c'est normal voilà c'est
c'est la règle c'était la raison en fait
c'est vachement bien pour artistiquement
parce qu'on peut reprendre des trucs par
contre il y a un gros flou juridique
c'est à dire que en termes d'argent on
ne sait pas qui prend l'argent alors
la voix utilisée ni gazeux qui a fait le
citron de l'original du titre en fait
c'est le mec qui a posté le son sur la
plateforme qui prend l'argent et ça
c'est un gros problème pour les artistes
juste peut-être on a on a la chance
d'avoir un apps donc
il va nous dire ce qu'il en pense tout à
l'heure il y a aucun problème c'est vrai
pardon parce que jusqu'à présent il y
avait le droit à l'image qui qui
régissait un peu tout et aujourd'hui
avec cet Arté avec cette intelligence
artificielle il y a un truc juridique là
il y a un flou juridique
sur les réseaux et ça fait des millions
de vues de l'oseille il y a des mecs qui
mettent TPMP d'ailleurs qui ont pas le
droit de le faire et qui bien sûr il y a
des contentieux
[Rires]
et c'est marrant parce que ça cartonne
sur Youtube mais par exemple sur les
sites de streaming comme Spotify c'est
formellement interdit donc ça ne passe
pas parce que sinon il serait condamné
alors je pense que vous connaissez tous
Emmanuel Macron
j'ai passé un moment un peu privé
[Applaudissements]
une fois j'ai vu aussi quand il était
ministre Emmanuel Macron il a un truc
quand il serre la mort regarde droit
dans les yeux exactement personne
exactement
c'est en train de se balader j'ai vu ces
gens de sécu avec les petits parapluie
et tout j'ai regardé si je me suis fait
ah merde mais il pleut pas là et en fait
je me suis approché mon dos des coups de
parapluie comme ça pour m'écarter tu
vois en fait c'était des trucs de
sécurité des matraques un peu tu vois
avec des espèces de parapluie comme ça
et ton écarté
alors et du coup en fait Macron il est
super bon délire parce que je l'ai vu
une vidéo de lui qui s'est fait piéger à
l'Elysée et pas par un gars et en fait
il fait une blague et tout il a super
bien réagi du coup bah en gros c'était
marrant tu fais ça sur Tik Tok hier
on va d'abord savoir ce qui s'est passé
la piégé avec le fameux défi des jeunes
là
tu as l'écran
il lui a expliqué ce que c'était un
sentiment pour le coup
[Musique]
en fait c'est une blague après la
personne elle doit dire hein après on
dit
vous connaissez pas et vous connaissez
quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
parce que il y a des mecs pourquoi
couper
d'accord avec moi vous savez que
Emmanuel Macron il a ordonné
formellement qu'on lui fasse rien
[Rires]
c'est très bien c'est très bien dit
c'est très bien c'est très bien ah alors
non on va passer à la dernière info
non c'est moi qui vais la faire
je vous l'avais dit hier on avait une
info sur une personne voilà pour la
rentrée des classes qui a été
amené de force par ses parents au lycée
il a décidé de prendre la fuite c'est un
truc de fou enfin c'est un truc
sympathique les gens c'est pas on
voulait absolument il voulait pas à
l'école ils ont amené à l'école
absolument ils ont dit tu vas à l'école
et il s'est Reba derrière il a fait une
vidéo Tik Tok regardez cette info
incroyable
c'est une histoire à peine croyable qui
a eu lieu hier jour de la rentrée des
classes pour près de 12 millions
d'élèves à travers la France après deux
mois de vacances la rentrée c'est le
retour à l'école ce matin une scène
cocasse s'est déroulée dans un lycée du
8e arrondissement de Paris au moment
d'amener leur enfant pour qu'il fasse sa
rentrée en seconde les parents ont vu
leur enfant fuir à toute allure au
moment de rentrer dans l'établissement
Le Petit Daniel a donc pris la fuite
avec son sweat à capuche et son cartable
sur le dos tout en ayant des mots très
durs envers ses professeurs
ce sont tous des Guignols tous
des Guignols Géraldine la maman du
turbulent en petit Daniel nous raconte
tout ce soir dans TPMP
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec les enfants ont vu la photo donc
ils ont vu l'émission ils ont appelé
tout le monde et c'est tout le monde
était cette photo est folle je vous dis
je vais la mettre en fond deck non mais
c'est sûr c'est sûr et certain je vais
vous avoir en fond deck les chéris j'ai
une autre info tu peux rester
c'est pour moi l'info à la fameuse de
ces vacances c'est l'info de cette
rentrée
bonjour tous des glaces
[Rires]
tu aimes bien les cônes ouais c'est très
bon très très bon j'en ai mangé un peu
cet été c'est avec de la crème de la
glace
d'accords
[Rires]
donc voilà merci toi c'est intéressant
ce que tu dis non mais c'est intéressant
artisanales je préfère
[Rires]
très bien
t'inquiète pas parce qu'il faut Jacques
carton pistache comme raisin moi c'est
ça je crois aux raisins ah ouais ouais
d'accord
magnifique italienne alors les gars moi
j'ai l'info et Alex Goude une fois de
plus c'est une très bonne rentrée
Alex good tu aimes les bouts oui
question est folle tu vas adorer mon
info
mon chéri pour ceux qui aiment manger
des cornets de glace
le kiff qu'on a pour les amateurs il a
raison c'est la fin parce qu'il met la
maison ils mettent un bout de chocolat
sur la fin
et bah maintenant il y a des gars ils
ont été très forts ils ont commercialisé
que les cul de cônes
et ça s'appelle ça s'appelle les cul de
cône euh voilà je vous le dis ça c'est
des connes c'est des cônes voilà dans
cet appel en fait ça s'appelle des bits
cons et Bitcoin les Bitcoin des Bitcoin
c'est génial
donc voilà et je vous dis et ça alors
j'ai dit le titre on va dire granola
petite écolier tout ça et voilà et en
fait ils ont fait que ça ils sont rendu
compte que les gens qui fait il y a une
marque qui a fait ça et qui fait que des
trucs maintenant que les bouts du cône
voilà est-ce qu'on peut les acheter
[Rires]
tu peux les acheter je vais essayer de
vous en avoir pour demain
merci est-ce que tu une dernière chose à
nous dire une dernière chose c'est bon
pour les enfants c'est bon c'est bon
pour les enfants un truc à dire perso
on se revoit quand mercredi prochain
ouais
tu prends un billet pour venir en bas
ouais c'est la prod qui me prend c'est
ça mourir pour mon train tranquillement
ah un billet de train
non non je te crois pas si si je te jure
que je regarde aussi j'ai 15 ans je peux
pas avoir encore
problème
[Rires]
je vais te faire des cadeaux alors c'est
vrai vas-y je suis chaud
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]